everybody welcome to stream Coco yeah
how's it going special guest today
Todd Levin welcomes everybody hi
everybody right that's what these kids
do yeah I'd say we're Taylor Swift
shirts you can't wait to close your
record here yeah exactly
that's what you do your vlogs and your
youtubes and your videos and your live
journals and all those things
welcome everyone we're gonna be playing
unravel to today I thought it was
unraveled but I guess it's unravel to
unravel too so its present tense its
unravel versus we've already unraveled I
like the world is currently unraveled
these guys are pretty well rivaled up
yeah they're very raveled and now
there's gonna be some unraveling and so
Todd is here not Todd is the guy a
behind clues gamer he just did the
Dragon Ball Z Dragon Ball legends I'm
sorry with Ron Funches this is the man
who pulls the strings and it all makes
it happen
and so now okay now we can go to the
game
I started this game six times and we had
to watch the cutscene six times because
before the thing because I'm not good at
new Oh half not like likes this intro
start we know don't start anew Oh cancel
okay I got a joint wait don't wait go
back
yes okay I got so I'm perfect all right
great here let's trade controller
psychic me you just made me trade
controllers just so you know I know
off camera can meet me trade
controller's about a minute before we
went I don't know what to do let me do
it again whenever I wear anything Taylor
Swift I one of these is made of
chocolate and one of them will help you
so we just said hey look at that I am a
dad looks like a dad because he is it
dad yeah I look good for a day no it's
great I'm trim I would say jawline I
would say here you who's the hottest guy
on staff your top three drew Shane drew
Shane our public yes what he has dead
eyes right like that a shark going in
for a title Patrick Bateman ah Patrick
Bateman eyes he has to return videotapes
a lot I say this is gonna be revealing
all my sort of my predilections from fur
I love this that's what we're it that's
what we do Eric cue cards is a very
attractive man Eric and cue cards Eric
kulakowski takes care of it works out a
lot it's got some must
yeah lookers there's a few look at your
top top three in my take care of your
rising seven says ten years ago I'd say
Chris Ultimo Wow going back you're right
he's a man have to steal that guy
absolutely take care of himself
abs of steel todd is very quiet yeah you
know what he's not yes please don't
please quiet compared yeah everyone is
quiet compared to me I'm like there's a
glass on the table next to like a t-rex
walking into Rasik Park
I'm the human equivalent of a glacier
breaking off and falling into the ocean
okay now we're gonna watch the cutscene
you ready that's true conversational and
it's terrible when I get even closer
because O'Malley just his ear there's a
drop of blood coming out of his ear
right now all right here we go
redlining we're finally gonna start the
new I'm very excited darting in ooh we
will lose everything but we start anew I
you know yeah that's - I'd say so yeah
that's definitely true
that's right greetings from Bosnia whoa
Edo a lot Bosnia what time is it over in
Bosnia George think it's not that's not
wow that thank you just positive a World
Cup team I think do they I know they're
in the World Cup or not you have to
qualify I don't really think they'll
tell you I here we go so far we're a
little yarn demon right looks like a
little yarn demon with horns and we've
fallen overboard I don't know why little
yarn people would have a boat yeah this
seems like an intense situation for a
yarn guy to be in right yeah this seems
very like they were like they watch the
movie castaway with Tom Hanks they're
like you know what this but yard people
oh what do they call yar knees do you
want to sit on the couch man
now all right that doesn't want to be
seen I don't want to like haha he's all
wet
yeah he's were covered oh now here's our
here's the other one of us to yardie
it's a the other offensive to call the
hashtag yar nice guys yeah I'm wearing
that one cookie I'm wearing a Taylor
Swift shirt it's from her tour I didn't
actually go see her the one of our cool
younger people in the office one of our
personal journeys territory Todd got me
this shirt
ooh now we now we're together forever so
far we're not doing anything yeah this
is great
I haven't moved yeah but now here's no I
don't want to I don't want to destroy
the whole premise for this game but
personally I feel like what go I'm read
wouldn't it be better if we weren't
attached to each other isn't that going
to be provide more obstacles did we just
do that on purpose I mean I guess oh
right oh hey Wow I jumped on you well
this is cool all right
ooh and we're also following fire which
i think is bad for yarn people so this
whole game I guess I'm just gonna be oh
I can play oh you gotta help me here we
go yarn ease unite to eat oh you know
what should I do you want to jump off me
when I jump this oh very smart there we
go
it doesn't seem like we're being that
constrained though with our yarns that's
a fart cuz we're all reveling with our
yarn
bilikiss is that how we die oh my god
cute oh oh this is so cute my treat
let's use this to push it and push it
through yeah oh no I'm trapped into that
aramis's that's what you are what do I
want no oh wait we want to push it back
do we want to push it back up can you I
don't know we already [ __ ] up I think
the game's over
greenies from Mexico hey Francisco munos
as a person of yarn I'm offended by your
nieces hath not
this it feels like you're taking me over
like I don't like it I'm like a say yes
like a parasite this jumped off your
yarn Paris Lee I do like the background
is like either photo realistic or
beautifully rendered yeah it's really
nice very cool it's really change what
your character looks oh cool how do you
just keep going
let's just keep going or do we want I
always want to but it's so boring to
watch somebody just change the colors
cut to an hour of us just like ooh those
OMG a chicken asks Todd just Conan also
punch you
Conan does not punch me he he has what I
think first of all he knows that I'm
very fragile I don't take a punch well
he takes a punch these people take
plenty do all that job but I what I
often get is instead I like a weirdly to
firm handshake like courier you I get
that oh no no no I'm in the water oh
wait you can change direction in the air
oh um how is it two people have never
shaken Conan's hand and what would you
what happened take us through that
experience does he how does he come in
hard low I'm high he comes in it's
Telegraph's he telegraph see put her
there
oh he does that he does it even say put
her there pal God and then he will
sometimes pat you on the back and then
he will then look examine his hand to
see what goo from your back that sounds
very accurate does he he never looks me
in the eye does he look you in the eye
yeah okay he now he it's always kind of
like prettier pal but then his hands
follow the thing and he's kind of
looking and I'm just assuming he's like
re-examining his life choices of shaky
mom you know if one of us get up there
then maybe the other one can pull the
other one up can they okay can I pull
you up
somehow can i oh wait
oh oh I'm Shh wait you can shoot a
little oh wait what am I am i pulling
you know yeah you are yeah how'd you do
that I don't know oh oh you pulled
yourself up nice oh wait so here's what
I do
oh we want to oh you know what we want
to do like the jump off jump off thing
okay hold on how did we do that I print
okay I'm just you know what I did I
ain't heard my thing with the left
trigger oh okay there oh nice now I'm
angry
no wait how did you do it please I'm
holding down left trigger oh oh you're
so just go pop on the direction oh
that's great oh this is so fine look at
us being pals oh that's cool oh that's
great your knees your knees for life
words with promises this is like the
time the journals spent ten minutes on a
tutorial for cuphead hmm but it's
funnier though I think we're more
entertaining than that there's a
journalist I think famously correct me
if I'm wrong and I know the internet
well that couldn't get past it - Torelli
cuphead and then like [ __ ] on the game
too hard for him yeah this is like well
by the way one of the greatest games
ever
that game is and I think they just
released a DLC for it or they announced
they're gonna do it with DLC and III um
here we go
do it pull it up I like that this game
well so far at least makes the
partnership a bonus rather than a
negative yes like in that game a way out
which we also played together that was
it that was a game that we had to do
everything twice and I could do stick
cool yeah great man here you go there we
go
I always love this part of every game
yeah I have to do like the back wall is
jumping off walls I know it did a lot of
games but it's so much fun for me and it
makes me think I could do it in real
life what you're good at something yeah
see if I hold this I think I gets like
shoot you up and over oh well you can
slide down jump off cool yeah what is it
if you missed that do we go wait do we
go to the right here do we go down I
don't know you tell me I'll follow you
look this game is like the partner game
of snipper clips yes have you ever
played snipper clip great game and I
love Super Clips again I just love like
such a fun brilliant idea simple idea is
that bird guna is that foreshadowing
that a bird is gonna mess us up oh you
know any mosquitoes oh we already here
I don't know oh do we want to go up I
think let's try oh hello rifle effect
from Korea good to see you oh no turn it
up nope it's pull it up exactly pull it
up baby
oh yeah I'll be doing another dinner in
a video game on Saturday she's very
exciting I'm gonna be doing PI rim
instead of Skyrim I'm finally gonna make
a pie good day yeah and I was thinking I
got to figure out what kind of pie to
make that's a big deal that's the whole
thing you already went this way again we
came up this way right yeah wait maybe
we go to the left yeah hook your boy up
okay climbing a rope something I can't
do now life while we're plugging things
I should also say that right now while
we're leanness there are babies in cages
that's true okay yes I just wanted to
plug that it's terrible it's this
perspective yes okay that's good
perspective is a good thing oh how did
you do that arty fish pie chicken pot
pie I made a fish pie you made myself
sick so we're not gonna be making a fish
pie I played horizon zero prawn made a
prawn and fish pie so that's all well
Jimmy go oh look at us we're like the
yarn version of Bear Grylls you have to
hold on Dorothy while you wear Bear
Grylls in it is that a verb can use oh
boy oh yes some crazy chicken Henning
chases you uh
oh nice oh this is great mmm you're like
John McClane but made of yarn Oh like
there we go womp I'm realizing that yarn
games are becoming a tiny genre I think
that's true each other a lot of yarn
game I guess well I mean a lot of like
handmade object kind of games yeah I
again I say did like a little big planet
when we were firing this up yeah the
kind of right there we go how are you
read that coming is I I'm realizing that
yeah McCain's games are becoming a tiny
John I was like I haven't played in my
life but I would you know what I think
yams I had an argument so many about
yams and sweet potatoes they're
different things oh I'm doing that thing
that like my dad would do the lasso
effect when you swing it's kind of
exciting
yeah well but you know what to be to be
fair and make you feel less old that is
something you do on the switch motion
controls everything I just realized
something about this game what do you
see how there's this little like fairy
wisp of light to the right of the screen
here watch yeah
it's telling us where to go oh I didn't
realize that I appreciate it right there
it's sort of guiding us this is such a
cute game Oh bro hopefully yarny out
hopefully yarny out here I'm anchoring
or tethering angry I want there to be a
little Reading Rainbow like when you
climb up you know what this reminds me
of I feel like we're playing on like a a
model train set yeah totally totally
also I will say oh [ __ ] did you see what
I did always [ __ ] dope I'm gonna try
to do to look at it oh I really like the
physics of this game
that's a gamer term physics I think
that's a science term whoa gamers like
Neil deGrasse Tyson yarny more space to
jump from
Oh take that spider-man homecoming oh
just think about how way how these your
knees must kind of smell pretty bad
yes they stink you know I don't want to
bring that up but the other thing I
don't really well that's to race against
the arunya is yarn it's yarnís t' the
other thing i don't really want to bring
up is I I do like the kind of mystical
music but it is kind of reminded me of
the Last of Us you hear like trickling
water does feel very darn it waffle turd
says Tom what were some three highlights
for you
you watched all the trailers free I did
did you watch The Last of Us - I didn't
watch though amazing laughs oh crap you
really have to get yours you have to get
some distance from that last one to make
it onto the branch No Last of Us that
was it blew me away but you know what
and I know that they say that they did
this on purpose but I think right now
like the world is so scary that I got
kind of freaked out by how vile it was
so much more than the first one oh wow
see I didn't see it I'm very into a
place right now I don't really want to
watch trailers for stuff I already know
I'm going to be you know yeah can I make
oh you know you can make your thing a
little longer again you can just go down
there I'm up finally nice that that was
really cool there was a trailer for a
game there's almost no information about
it yet but there's a game called control
but it would look really cool because it
was by the makers of Max Payne
oh no what's that I haven't seen that
it's like very inception II like it's
got all these like the environments are
kind of almost look like high-resolution
minecraft and they just constantly
change whoa the environments you're in
what did who's asking that uh waffle
hurts
hey waffle what did you like oh that's
what she said make your thing a little
longer says Marco meatball fair enough
aah chain saw Rosenberg this game is
awesome I would say this game is really
fun yeah more fun to play with pals
aren't still fun and nonetheless yeah I
would imagine smells really nice and
below me where we are very low me oh
here we go so do you want to try to get
up there it's our yarn just forever long
I mean Kimmie's look oh no oh wait go to
the other yeah you know what we enter an
interesting mechanic in this game and
maybe it's gonna happen is the longer
our thing gets the less we it like pulls
us out oh oh we get small like you can't
go too far yeah lucky yeah you turn into
a small yarny alter so I was also
greatly impressed by control that might
be the one I've the most interest in
2077 looks great I love that yeah but
you know what I I think it looks really
cool yeah but I I have a hard time any
of those really deep arty RPGs mm-hmm
because you spend a lot of time talking
to merchants that's true in Witcher 3
and that one will be really cool
merchants it'll be like someone like
selling Bitcoin because it's like
cyberpunk like oh I'm buying like cool
like flash drive awesome mini disk nano
patches yeah but it's still the same is
like getting a flagon of mead with your
games which which into that Witcher was
very talky which was one of the things
we did for the clueless gamer yes that
my favorite part of that was like how
you would talk to your character yeah
and you'd be like well if you want to
know that talk to this other other guy
could have I'm sorry did you need
something for me instead you have to
like go
disengage and then walk over and tell
you that there's a lot of that well man
which was great I feel like up there are
unicorns you can have sex on in
cyberpunk probably digital unicorns yeah
cyber cyber Korn probably the proper
term who trot if this came out a form
I'd like to read some of the threads
well played well played well played
have I ever played odin sphere
no I've never heard of it we ever heard
of odin sphere but I'd like to I just
played a quick plug for a really great
and interesting game I played on the
switch over the weekend
goroh Goa how is this gonna work
oh I see you gotta press X and then you
ya go over nice oh wow
whoa cool that's cool that's great
gorgoa is in the same vein it's an indie
game and the same vein is braid where it
was like one guy who made it it's a
puzzle game I hear you want to get up
here I've got to my what's this about
I think we have to get through somehow
something about the knots here can we
pull a knot and pull it or something
Gorgo is a game and it's basically these
four panels and it's a puzzle game where
the guy drew it all by hand
and you can beat it in a day and you
move these scenes over in different
parts of them move with as you move them
in different parts stay behind and then
it becomes new scenes and so you're
following this boy who kind of sees this
monster and then he's kind of trying to
figure out through the rest of his life
it takes you through the rest of his
life what the monster is and what it's
about and also it's very beautiful game
very chill it makes you feel smart even
though you're just moving things around
goroh go on the name is the thing that's
sucky about cuz he can't remember
goregoan yeah yeah and that's how a term
he came up with he was a kid it was his
favorite word so I get it man I get it
but go play Gore ago it's really fun so
it looks like we're supposed to go up
there but I don't quite know how okay I
keep wondering if you could you know
what you can scroll through the hints
you better not do that again thanks a
lot we're goes one of the top switch
games apparently very affordable I think
it's under 10 bucks yeah it's like 10 or
12 a hundred percent worth looking down
oh that's cool you're just chilling it
says to scroll with the d-pad to the
right oh these are little emotes what's
not giving us oh yeah
Oh hit l1 oh there we go here one now we
can scroll through this great how'd you
get rid of that I don't know I was just
scrolling through the hints wait what
maybe I don't know me I have no idea
what happened whoa maybe just wanted us
to scroll through the hints
ooh push objects over bridges I see a
bridge situation wait so how did you do
that you did this and then you pressed X
how do you do the not fit yeah you press
X and then you press X to the next
anchor point - oh I see oh wait so all
I'm doing today yet don't do that yet oh
yeah we got to do it we got a thing I'm
gonna push this thing over the bridge so
push your back thoughts on the oddity
that is death stranding I think it looks
great it looks cool and weird oh yeah
I'm into cool and weird yes I'll bet
it'll be super bizarre it looks like a
lot of carrying packages different
places which is fun I always love a good
package carry game they just want to oh
they Cletus says Cletus - Minaj says
they just wanted us to scroll through
the hints that was the point yeah we got
past that web oh really is literally to
help to make a scroll to minutes okay
all right so how did you yeah I made the
bridge okay cool now push that guy over
the bridge perfect strong a spleen this
is some strong magical yarn this is cool
yeah so then you have to undo you're not
by the way did you know who's behind the
keyboard is this magic it's magic
it's Beth y'all backage caring game so
it's Shenmue I mean basically doesn't it
look like that to you which game uh
death stranding oh did you watch
anything yeah it's just I still have not
mastered this anchor thing I think we
have to tie anchors and then jump up
okay oh cool we just mean yeah oh there
we go
there how's that it yeah yeah can we do
it again up here cool you under you're
not there okay oh [ __ ]
sorry dude oh that's alright way too
well yeah you can pull me up brother
okay so we're gonna I'm gonna make redo
this not okay okay okay okay good
all right and then bounce and then
tether and then under you're not down
below right
yeah and redo a new one I think so I
think you didn't under yours oh maybe I
didn't undo mind I'm not good with this
nothing did you have to hit B to undo
your not kiddo oh I see okay guy there
undone and then remember you've got it
all right
teamwork okay Todd just telling me what
to do because he's smart I wouldn't be
surprised evolved s training ends up
being very different than what's shown
so far I mean I hope so and there's like
the idea that they're using a baby as a
lantern yeah that's cool it's like a
weird Seoul Lantern oh gotta undo my
knot
yeah I mean also there's a whole number
gamma del Toro and that whole thing with
mads mikkelsen and there's like a city
that stuff I mean that has got a plan to
it also exact there are adults in there
chainsaw Rosenburg that's true I'm
thinking in the chat do not undo any
knots down below got it keep it civil
we're trying but you know wait how did
you get all the way up there oh wait you
have to go help yeah
left trigger and then up oh Jesus whoops
oh maybe we go down here anyway this
training will deaths trainee will be a
tower defense game that would be
hilarious yeah do you invent mow Todd
some money he's a debt he's a father
yeah I really want an LCD projector
really yeah I want it cuz I like doing
movies in Oh No
I was just gonna work okay let's see
team working
where's Conan Conan's in France
currently he's in candy okay oh damn
stay where you are stay we're sorry
sorry sorry
whoops did the exact I should have just
not touched the controller but I clean
again yarn
yeah friggin Yanni what's wrong with you
okay okay stay there stay there
watch this I hold LT I wanted to swing
like crazy you know I got some pretty
good pretty good
I got some good strengthen now you hold
LT my arms being made in your arms
pulling you up look at that
that's great this game is a door I get
this gate I don't usually plug games but
I love this this is so fun could you
play this loner you have to play online
if you're not with I go no you can't
play alone you can definitely play a
little swing to that guy I'm not exactly
sure how that would work
I wonder if I can oh sorry
okay she's like I'm putting you out here
but you can make your Jesus so you know
do you just want to swing I don't need
you for this winger you're just better
at swinging big-fish games gets into
gaming trends what I'm not sure what big
fish games is I hit the thing I knocked
myself out oh right I'll put my god oh
you can loop it over an object too so
watch this
so that's got to be what it's that's how
you do it by yourself you must it must
be a lot of last something it's a lot of
this is basically just cause with yarn
game is couch co-op and no online as far
as I know it kind of sucks that's true I
mean Katherine although you know what I
been doing playing a lot of state of
decay too lately which does have online
co-op and it's tough man the online
thing is tough
oh look at this whoa you can make it how
long does this yarn go there we go no I
can pull you pull yourself up and I'll
just again I'll just pull myself over
I'm a lazy the cameras kind of get me
nauseous
um I'm not feeling that but I guess I
could see how about watching you might
feel that way because we're not playing
well also yeah if it's a factor if it's
a small what happened oh no okay I'll
just wait you do your swing thing so I'm
gonna you do that swing thing you doing
thing this close camera go to e3 we
didn't this year we have in the past I
mean I dunno what do it okay share my
feelings about all about you three
please overall oh the other game I was
excited about was Skull and Bones I
didn't see that that's the pirate game
it looks really cool oh nice I wouldn't
think that you would I wouldn't think
I'm gonna try to swing game yeah but it
looks really cool there you go yeah
sorry but I was gonna say about e3 is
just an overall feeling that was that
these consoles feel like a throw at the
end of their life cycle oh yeah and I'm
not making like really new provocative
games although control looked that way
and that's why I was excited about it
what they're doing is they're making the
best looking games yeah these consoles
so the game is overall looks like
gorgeous but they were kind of
incrementally built on what they've done
before so I kind of feel like
next year's e3 or maybe even a year
after it's gonna be really the one
that's gonna be doubts cuz it'll have
the new generation how do I let the
thing go again just let go like whatever
you're doing now just let go
wait but I've tried to oh hey oh hit is
a jump it's scooby's it's not for some
reason are you holding down anything are
you alt down no I'm not oh there we go
all right finally sorry everybody
I'm just saying educate you I've just
moved my survivors into a strip mall oh
man I've got to get my doctor got eaten
and that was a problem and I was like
screaming standing up like no like it
was very yeah it sucked it's now like
all my people are just like alright so
you do want to do a swing thing hoping
Red Dead - and rock star are really are
invented after all GTA 5 was a major
change of pace with the three characters
that's true I agree with that
yeah that was cool that was cool I have
high hopes for Red Dead - I think it's
gonna be really cool I think that as
long as they don't get overly involved
with the online multiplayer situation I
think it's like so seductive for game
developers cuz they're like ooh like
more people we can sign them up to an
account and you know all this stuff yeah
but it's like not a fun experience I
don't think for me at least I haven't
people really loved it like doing heists
together I just never got into it you
know yeah I mean I get it it's just I
think that it's just such a different I
guess well I guess well I'll say is I
think that it's done a lot oh my gosh
that's cool a lot of times I think the
online multiplayer is to focus rather
than and they kind of leave the
first-person stuff I would like I mean
just make sure that the first that you
know the first player is great don't it
don't abandon your base yep gonna be on
your [ __ ]
haiman games do that for money IG I
agree G honey oh you know Jesus I'm
sorry
I'm definitely time to forever held my
rhythm is before I ever held together by
yarn just cut yourself loose when you're
holding you back
oh no there you go where's all up yeah
that's cute what just happened
Red Dead 2 battle royale would be a big
hint like West world I think this has
got to be a jump
oh yeah there's got to be like a jump
lastest situation yeah I was trying to
do that but I think I just missed or
maybe I wasn't jumping but is there a
different game or wait or do you want it
wait a second do you want to go down off
me and then try to swing up there no I
guess you can I don't think so I think
your tool over let me see if I can just
do this all right let's do it
uh Kip the snuggler Aaron which III
reveals made me pop off the most well I
do like to pop off I was popping off
cyberpunk I was popping off yeah you're
popping off in the bathroom I'm right
here yeah exactly
yes wow that's amazing clear the pipe so
I could clear this on this game clear
those pipes - popping off pipes okay so
this should I would think that this
would let us oh so do we want to hear I
think oh I see I see
look you want me to move this back again
no get up on to that those leaves do you
oh here we go this is the physics of
this are very fun yeah there we go okay
so I'm gonna just jump off and
I was popping off reported as Team Coco
played VR chat Robert Burns we have not
I mean about get in the bucket with me
what was the thing a mouse what was the
VR thing we did that was like Second
Life we escaped the Bane prison VR chat
is a new thing yeah you mean I could be
in a world of memes Oh
sign me up
I like to communicate via chips
yeah it's gift food oh you passed
creator I defer to him sherilyn says
this coco channel is uber cool thanks
cherylin oh I love it
all right there we go oh lighthouse
lighthouse in which we choose our path
this is great like this I'll never play
it again because I don't have any
friends I'm literally being carried
that's true I am I am Todd is carrying
this whole thing um the arch at Conan
wouldn't cut in VR chat would not be TV
or advertise her friendly he's not
normally a VR guy no although he did
like some of the stuff we did when we
went to the youtubes VR lab in New York
yeah I think he would like the void he
did that I think he would - yeah that
Star Wars thing mm-hmm yeah I think yeah
he liked what did he like he liked the
space pirates thing he didn't he thought
the boxing thing was funny
and you know in a certain way I think VR
is better for him because it's more
intuitive versus like all this stuff so
yeah I think he would yeah I mean now
what he would say in VR would probably
be I'm getting more into VR now that
it's less tethered hmm you know you used
to bum me out how tethered it all was
yeah and it was kind of it's not a funny
look I don't know oh my God look at this
oh oh I see oh this goes up the way
right oh yeah wait so let go of it there
we go
perfect so it's really well
there's a lock oh there's a lock okay so
we got a lot of figure out to lock oh
now let's see this is great this is like
a fun what's going on a parent wait what
just happened perfect
nailed it now is that whole level right
I don't know yeah he hated it
well since fart yes exactly well he
didn't like the thing is like the the VR
aspect of Wilson's heart I think he
liked the actual game like most games he
didn't like because he doesn't like
videogames yes and also it was a bit
silly it's a bit silly and it's like a
lot of talking and then you're not
walking anywhere you're just teleporting
yourself mm-hmm and you spent a lot of
time opening envelopes and picking up
documents I don't know now to say that I
was not a big fan of oh sorry this is
now turning very creepy this is either a
home invasion or sure what's happening
here oh this is gonna be like that movie
have you seen hereditary no oh but I
miss you tomorrow okay don't tell me
does it have your knees in it no I don't
say anything it's got a very important
there's a string or wire very it appears
in large dude don't say I left so hard
I'm playing the boxing thing that's true
the boxing thing was great I remember
watching cut up so we read was a Comic
Con and the caster's Suicide Squad
that's right
that was oh my god what's that last year
two years ago who sues that's quite two
years ago that was great well it's it's
great I gotta say man Will Smith enjoys
being Will Smith he just he's always
Will Smith he came on he was just that
whole thing and he was loving it and all
that stuff and then didn't you come back
at some point
did you sorry they keep somebody out
we're watching like the memories of
somebody no interesting so what does
yarny have to do with any of this
maybe this is maybe were the souls of
soul this kid or something yeah cuz look
she's wearing orange and blue yeah there
we go there we go we were her yard
that's how we're connected to every yard
yeah literally this shirt it's
depressing uh well he doesn't like video
games but some of the close gamers you
can tell he appreciates it except
which are we feeling like for the sex
scenes but that's all of us yeah it's
true no he just like games he like
minecraft there's certain games you
really like that he really did actually
like Dragonball Legends because it was
easy for him to play can you jump on oh
yeah sorry I think the I think the thing
wait here yo this thing but then you
can't get up yes he actually there are
some video games he really likes no
we've played he really likes any should
voiceover anime didn't we do that we did
we do that we've done that are we gonna
like trip the parent or something wait
what just happened well I don't know but
I can't I'm not controlling please guard
the window somehow look she's gonna
let's go I don't want to know why we
couldn't get that elevator work I feel
like we messed up something there I know
we definitely screwed something up oh
wait no wait there's another tether
point up here oh I think this is just to
get us up to this pedestal right sure
yeah cuz you can't jump on this thing
oh we have bouncer here yeah get to you
want to make a little like a like a
little weds a bridge a little bridge how
do we do that again yes there we go
sorry Peggy oh the music's getting more
intense
oh no damn it here Dragon Ball legends
but one of the best clothes schemers in
a while probably cuz Mahon fizzy acid
Ron Funches is yes I felt like oh let me
just climb down here and I'll go into
this hole I felt Ron Funches I was so
excited to get he was the perfect guy he
I he was really great it was about it
yes and he's he was a little fan like
you know like I sent a video to Todd
when we booked Ron I sent a video to
Todd that was on Ron's Twitter that was
like getting ready for this he was
actually talking about Dragon Ball
fighters II but he's like getting ready
for doing all fighters II and just
showed like the Dragon Ball Z super
cartoon and then his face and he was
like I was like oh this is gonna be a
great game that's really fun okay where
are we we're not weird yeah I guess
we're in an attic cuz we is Conan
actually Goku I'd say he's more no he's
not go qu Oh do we want to get in there
damn want to run towards the fire don't
be afraid of it yarny yeah I know if I
were yarn I would be like anything that
looks like fire are you good no no
thanks that's right I rise e7 yes the
chat got Conan to say ultra instincts
from Dragon Ball Z I didn't understand
that was from Dragon Ball when we did it
oh no oh no don't don't follow me don't
follow me
oh no have you cancelled the gaming
episode with Conan just because it
wasn't funny enough no that's never
happened was there one that we but no
normally I would say and todrick knows
more about this night but I would say
when something is shot we just try you
try to make it funny yeah and you kind
of know you kind of know what you have
yeah and you're like what and also when
you're shooting it you know also and
coke I would say normally is very good
about like do we have it
you know lady won't stop this over here
yeah and he because he wants it to be
good too because he's the one who has to
show it so yeah so no I would say that
process probably is the fact that you
don't happen that we don't cut stuff
after we've shot it with Conan when it
comes to like remotes than those things
oh boy cool cool your knee got burned up
start the yardie death death count 1 but
yeah so I would say first of all when
we're shooting remotes
we kind of know if we have it or not I
mean Conan is makes you know sure we
have it the same thing is like you can
always make it short I mean I think with
some clueless gamers we've gotten into a
situation where we've shot stuff and
it's not as great as we thought it was
in the room and then you know you just
cut it down and you eventually get stuff
and there's also jokes a nice thank you
there's also little jokes to be added
after the fact that we don't always know
are gonna happen in the room a good
example of that is when we did I think
the last Super Bowl game with Tom Brady
and Gronk started Gronk started talking
about his water bottle and under a do
Boucher another writer came up with a
really funny joke to turn that into a
Home Shopping Network advertisement
while it was happening and that wasn't
something that was we thought about in
the room that just came up in post yeah
we did that with um Von Miller - yeah
where he the chicken he had a chicken
for me to get fired yeah so a lot of
times you know like even if you come
back to the Edit room and stuff isn't as
as great as you want it to be you can
always add things in post to kind of
help it and also never forget like you
know corn is also such as oh wow oh
goodness the smoke monster from from
lost is in this
see there's an orange kid in the room is
this a sequel to the purge the first
Kurtis this is a very odd game it's so
interesting - there's no dialogue or
anything you're just kind of feeling it
out look yeah that's why they don't want
to touch the embers these are my
favorite kinds of games that have
world-building without without a lot of
talking the other thing too is like you
know you have to remember like Conan it
oh boy
Conan is brilliant also so so I'll never
forget like when I was an intern I
remember one of the very first
rehearsals I was watching like his his
ability to edit and his instincts are so
amazing like there's this one sketch a
camera what it was and it kind of the
end wasn't great and he made a little
blob wait till he comes down yeah and he
kind of was like oh you know he's like
why don't we do this he's like let's get
a shot of me going No - up above well
freeze frame and then credits and I was
like that's so weird
and that's exactly that's exactly what
it what happened and it worked perfectly
so you know even if oh this is this is
exactly a cigarette ember it's like a
wall of yeah so yeah that's the thing
too is like even if you are showing
something in rehearsal that you're not
quite sure is a hundred percent he will
make it a hundred percent oh Jesus sorry
oh sorry that was my fault if you have
to get that deaf count five Gingras is
honest oh yeah you want talking about
your brother Adam Levine is so fat he's
super famous yeah it's it's kind of a
source of frustration for me yeah very
famous and has a different last name
yeah my name is similar enough yeah that
yes of course we're cousins Todd I
wonder if understand you guys talk about
how your custody ever hurt her
Andy ever heard
Todd I wonder if understanding the art
of script running gets in the way of
enjoying a good story because you can
guess how most events turn out you know
what I I would say I do do a little bit
of that I think a lot of comedy writers
do of kind of like oh I see what you did
there
oh that you could also lasso you see a
pony up if you wanna do it that way the
probably better way to do it yeah you do
sort of see like you see the moves
oh you mean you start you all start
watching this whoops I'm looped around
coming down oh crap here I'll come back
down it's okay I think you can just do
oh [ __ ]
that's the three-act structure curse
you'll see the yeah you'll see like oh I
see what you're doing that that turn or
this thing I don't know I've just seen
enough comedy that's it makes it hard
but I do but but it makes me appreciate
it that much more when I do laugh at
something
oh Jesus and something surprises me you
know anyway wait stay there cool you
funny I wanted you to swing witness my
death so we're here but witnessing just
here doing a swing oh yeah do you swing
do you swing thing torch a jig what's
your favorite game of all time I know
it's a hard question but what's your
what's your top 3d what's your top three
games Red Dead Redemption is in the top
last of us and then
just for pure agent enjoyment
I mean like honestly Super Mario
Brothers 3 oh wow like I love that game
so much that's awesome
here help me push this over I think from
the other side maybe it's a push from
the other sides oh you know what I
wonder if we push this back the other
way oh yes let's stay there oh is that
right
there's that
is this the right thing oh yeah you know
what and then go back down and under
I'll keep it like this then you can
found so what I was gonna say you go
back down under and then you can found
like this so you can persist yeah DEFCON
8 m Bert how many famous movie or TV
people follow you on twitter because I
got followed by two and one it's through
a TV show on Comedy Central awesome that
feels more like you're bragging that
question it doesn't feel like you just
followed by someone that you consider
famous no one famous follows me and
that's fine anybody famous follow you
that you're excited about
I'm trying to besides Adam Levine your
cousin you know I you know I was trying
to capitalize on his fame too much
Twitter I was like so typical I was like
Todd Levine I would say that me and my
cousin Adam Levine are on the same page
this issue and they'd sometimes be
really offensive things things that he
should be honest I'm trying to remember
like everyone again I'll screenshot
somebody who follows me love just to
show my wife like what there were a
couple people that really were
surprising it doesn't really matter you
know what I mean because really it's
about the regular people
the fans yeah this you know this game is
very Spider Man esque
mm-hm slow like see it's like super sex
butter man he got me all watery got me
all wet
oh well you know what maybe we owe its I
think you don't know about the Todd fan
club all right
I called my fan club the maroon 5 should
I not be doing no I be mad I think until
litigation happens it's all good okay
well there they are underneath the thing
guys we have to go in about two minutes
so get your last question is end for the
great Todd Levin questions on Adam
Levine clueless gamer or even just more
comments like Todd's got a sweet
mustache that's fine that's a great
comment one of my faves
oh wait you know we want to do I know we
wanna do okay and then get up there and
then we do watch this wha
oh you mean do a swing like oh don't
breathe yeah I've got a few myself oh
you okay oh you wanna do a swing thing
yeah but you do it watch oh nice oh so
smart you're not just another pretty
mustache um wall emotion have you had
lunch yet no no we're going to after
this it's gonna be great now where's
your sauce I don't usually do is I had
breakfast at Subway oh I had an egg
white wrap and there was a really cute
old couple at the subway what a guy was
wearing a bowtie oh my god yeah and it
was sweet and also a little sad oh my
god that's amazing yeah this little this
cute little old couple and I really
wondered about them because they were
dressed like so fancy but they were out
of Subway eating in either subway which
is also weird oh maybe it's where they
first met before they made their first
billion um we want to keep rolling back
all right we're gonna get we're gonna
figure out this puzzle then we're gonna
say goodbye oh sorry
this is how I skateboard though dude
this is me ski for this is you're
terrible at it I'm underneath like
underneath this deep way I'm more of a
bored skater everybody can go
skateboarding so I'm gonna push it
and push it as much as I can then jump
on nice then get up yeah they get up oh
oh Jesus you know you're okay so watch
this again
nope yeah fard says where where would
you like to do a week of shows that you
haven't yet I can tell you where Austin
Austin be great Detroit Detroit be great
Detroit is my dream I would love to do
only come shows in Detroit and I've
pitched it many many many times I would
love it I'm from Michigan
I'd be great Reykjavik right Kimmie
great like when I'd like to do Reykjavik
when it's here you pull yourself up
endless endless light I have I want to
do in our cool ski all right all right
yeah come on all right let's go to a
skateboard shake right we want to roll
up dude and then we'll just jump off at
the top okay so I mean oh hi I'm johnny
Knoxville and this is the yarny
skateboard right and then we go back up
and we are gonna jump off the skateboard
[Laughter]
okay
do you believe in extraterrestrials sure
why not because I it's very it's a very
kind of self-centered thing to think
that we're alone now out here oh Jesus
we are Y are nice this is our story
opportunity for play and we just ruined
it
oh no we can't just get on it we'll get
up no yardies aren't you glad we decided
to save this puzzle for last yeah this
is great
the one that we cannot do here we go
ready
I'm gonna push you up then we'll do it
okay push the skateboard up the other
side of the road
oh so dumb we're so dumb that's where
you want to build momentum of course
clearly we're not skateboarders grind
goofy god damn it Todd get up here all
right we did it
10 11 everybody before we go can we go
fullscreen real quick puffles grants odd
people mountains requested a can you
show us how you do your boomerangs your
live boomerangs instagram we're gonna go
out in a lifetime - am i that's right
right here we go and go boom oh right
thanks for joining us everybody we'll
see you guys later peace out